um it's been dope to see the Resurgence
of Rich Forever in terms of you know
it's good to see Dex doing well yeah you
know he has some low times that we all
are aware of uh and obviously Jay critch
has been eating for a long time for sure
yeah we've been working on the rich
rapper five well it's like pretty much
done now you know
and J crew just put out his Juke season
project so it was just like
we back to it you know what I'm saying
for you like being a CEO being kind of
the leader of the crew what what were
some of the things that you kind of had
to you know because I feel like we saw
Dex kind of struggle with his
sobriety you know staying in the right
right state of mind and it seems like
he's doing really well now for you was
that something that was like
um hard to deal with like because you
know sometimes when I've I had a lot of
people in my life that have dealt with
addiction you know what I mean I know
that it's it's a heartbreaking thing to
go through it sure is definitely
frustrating you know
like watching somebody like go to rehab
and then go back to it and then like
you know it's just frustrating but you
it's like my brother you're right it's
like I understand it's my artist but
it's like my real family and I'll be
[__] up if anything happened to him so
it's like I gotta put that first that
friendship you gotta put the human part
first before the artist should for the
industry should be good bro like that
was the most important part to me yeah
how how far along is Rich Forever five
is it done or is it it's pretty much
done yeah we had like
um like
two weeks in the studio it's locked in
is it just you three because I know you
have other okay
you know the fans been just wanting the
project from us three so
um
I'm about to see what what level I'm
gonna put it all through um
do you feel like you get enough credit
for being the CEO that you are man
because I do feel like if we kind of
rewind time in 2018 2019 like I was one
of the first CEOs yeah well I just mean
in terms of like you know I do feel like
Rich Forever is a movement I feel like
you guys got [__] plaques you guys
got numbers on the board you know what I
mean and I feel like uh sometimes maybe
people don't necessarily give you that
credit
um yeah man you know that's how I be a
lot of [__] don't get credit
for a lot of [__] true you know so
I'd be like work harder nobody cares
work hard you know I'm saying that's why
I'm signing more artists I'm dropping
more [__] we got rich for having five
dicks guys project coming out I got my
album coming out you know what I'm
saying so
gotta go harder man do you feel like um
you've also grown a lot in the last few
years because I feel like he's matured a
lot I feel like I see you moving a
little differently you know what I mean
I feel like it kind of in in terms of
just everybody kind of grows if you
stand the same you're [__] up you
know what I mean yeah for sure learn a
lot you learn a lot
you know you get hit with life for sure